what's your biggest issue with society
today because it seems like you've got a
bone to pick polarization
I I'm afraid I worry that that nobody
can even agree on where the truth is
coming from we never had that problem
that's new for me and what I mean by
that is back in the day I could go I
heard on the news bro and we go well the
news is vetted I trust the news oh what
did you hear it on CNN or Fox because my
dad always said in the New York Times is
always lean left but you still trust it
as a source of information there's no
question the New York Times was a
trusted source of information so was the
Wall Street Journal even though I had a
much bigger report the audience that
doesn't know what did your dad do for a
living my dad was uh I I grew up all
over the world
you know what I mean I grew up all over
the world wasn't like a CIA hey
come out here you you keep waking up
free every morning
as a banker yeah worked at Citibank and
we lived in I was born in the
Philippines I lived in uh Calcutta and
then Bombay and then Lebanon then
Pakistan the Lebanon Lebanon again then
Greece definitely events
honey what do you do for them why do you
leave three months at a time baby this
is a big deal big private Equity deal
we're working we also True Lies it was
Arnold Schwarzenegger buddy man a man
can't can't do work Beirut during war so
your dad said even though New York Times
has left it's vetted so you can trust me
yeah yeah and I and I think to
think now when I when I say something
like no I heard it on Tucker Carlson or
I heard it on CNN I lose half the room
because they go They're liars and I
think that's a problem right the the
biggest
maybe challenge that we face is that
when you can no longer agree on one
source of Truth you are going to have
people that not only align themselves
with their own Echo chamber and align
themselves with the kind of truth that
that fits their narrative right that
confirmation bias but you have an entire
mechanism of information that allows you
to get pushed even further in that
direction or even further in this
direction right and now you've got two
you you have almost this this cyber
Civil War that could happen you get
these parallel economies and people have
talked about this way more eloquently
than I have but it kind of Harkens back
to the
phenomenon that allowed Europe to have a
40-year Civil War World War one and
World War II
was maybe you could make the argument an
offshoot of the fact that truth itself
became atomized I mean let me give you
an example it used to be there was no
question about what time was and now
Along Comes Einstein and says time is
relative
what oh by the way time might bend and
uh and and light bends and oh I can
predict the movement of the planets you
don't need the Bible for that bro let me
explain something and and Haley came
along and said yeah Haley's common all
of a sudden we go whoa whoa wait a
minute that's kind of nutty and then you
have a guy named
um Freud who comes along and says hey
there's you're unconscious and there's
conscious there's also something called
the subconscious and oh by the way you
want to have sex with your mother
there you go there you go Europe a deal
with that you want to have sex with your
mother oh and and by the way you're
ruthless about your sexual selection and
then another guy comes along named
Darwin and says hey um there's something
called Evolution there's design without
a designer God doesn't exist don't need
him uh there's also something called
sexual selection and it's ruthless maybe
women actually like the guy with the
strongest jaw the broader shoulders and
the most aggression and all of a sudden
we go hold on but the meek shall inherit
the earth that's cool dude yeah you go
about the three-legged dog I'm getting
this I'm getting the four-legged dog
with a strong bite and I want I want
good guns and that and and that's why
when Nietzsche said God is dead
what he meant was
God may be dead but human beings are
religious anyway and we're going to come
up with our own religions and our
religions are going to be communism
fascism capitalism we're going to come
up with our own religions and the
problem with that is that now you got
ideologies and when you have ideologies
you have camps and then you have
charismatic people that have control of
the guns that take over like Stalin like
Hitler right who say um this is the new
truth and oh by the way I'm going to
reshape society as the Utopia I Envision
we can make human beings perfect we can
make Society perfect so you might be
flawed now but kiss my ass I'm gonna
make all you perfect and the other ones
who are a lot there are some people by
the way who we can't educate you guys
you guys a little older you gotta go
you gotta go you got I can't it's just
business I gotta purify I gotta break a
couple eggs to make an omelette this is
what happened and so if you think that
can't happen today
I would only say that I promise you
Stalin's Russia and Hitler's Germany
said the exact same thing before they
came to power
you know it's like it could never happen
here yeah they said the same thing I
mean that's a pretty bleak thing again I
need music so you're very I need music
so you're very optimistic about the
future I I actually am yeah I think you
are I am in your own dark way you're
optimistic that good things are around
the corner well because human beings
figure their way through men yeah I'm
just talking a lot but people are like
their people are aware of the things I'm
saying
you like you're not are you are you more
depressed now that I brought that up no
you're like no no Pat says all the time
the future looks bright future looks
bright so there's no one that's gonna
tell me why tell me why you're give me
get me out of my uh why I think the
future looks bright yeah oh one million
percent future looks bright because
exactly what you went back to uh you
know you know how you said the hall pass
guys and and the guys that uh uh the
bully who bullied until he finally
realized that you uh got the one kid you
bully to spend ten thousand hours
learning how to fight and then he came
back and he not only whooped your ass
but you knew you could no longer cross
so what what bullies don't realize they
do is they they create a Michael Jordan
they create a Dave Chappelle they create
a Joe Rogan they create a uh
they create any of those oh of course no
question I mean bullying comes in
different forms bullying is not just
about being a kid bullying is you know
somebody with money that you know their
money came from family and maybe they're
imposing themselves on you a little bit
and you're sitting there saying dude I
would whoop your ass and I'm gonna
outwork your ass here okay no problem
let's see what's gonna happen here and
then you go out and prove your point so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]